yeah welcome Saturn set satchel 36 it's
my opponent here from the Philippines
right yep from the Philippines oh ok
maybe a king's indian he's taking his
time get the fianchetto variation that's
not very exciting no he's feeling
shattering after all ok let's try for a
c5 base setup not for the classical
variation ok maybe I can provoke him to
play d5 this is an interesting try for
black ok
oh hey it's got a good rating but it's
very slow in this verse moose I mean I'm
I'm also not very it's not so not a very
experienced player there on the ICC yeah
this Queen a5h five line is interesting
yeah k is playing the solid the solid
wave just allowing the screen trade
there are some pin some more some more
aggressive ways to to tackle that as
wide but i think i recently got that one
actually in a in a blitz game and ahead
song some quite substantial problems if
i remember correctly okay so ride c5 how
do I untangle and b6 he has if I if this
is this is a problem I think I played
rook the eighth in that in that other
game and I really couldn't equalize yeah
still I mean I have to play a move and
cannot I cannot spend huge amount of
time here
okay not quite sure what this what this
move is doing ok maybe he wants to put a
can 95 but hmm it looks Jack looks a bit
unassuming okay i have 96 now I think
197 just trading yeah maybe 97 that that
is a simple way to trade stuff
especially considering that you went to
d 2 which is blocking the D file okay so
yes 95 as a move but I can play ecigs
and I want to go nigh de5 next
activating all right let's be quick here
yeah an ID hive is a problem now e seven
hangs and there's invasion on c7 I
cannot play a 6am
that was a bad idea getting into this
and shaky game shaky position um he's
six maybe
now he has to yes to go forward them
it's quite clear okay rook be 18 if he
goes b5 I have 94 which at least them is
a tempo Oh what is this I didn't expect
that move at all when I can take rook e8
would just be opinion at least it wrong
for him yeah but ok it's it's ok
hmm but if I go 94 am I not then I
threatening nitey to write and taking
cannot be the solution really i don't
believe that and why did think
huh I mean by Bishop 1d4 is such a good
piece I mean how is this good for white
I don't see it
maybe rooked you won a five-night b5
something like that but i have put
should be six to cover the eight that's
very important there that i can cover d8
also night be 5pm night be 5 i'm going
to push it back to be 6 covering c7
uncovering d6s re d8 covering the aid if
it goes d6 i can just play Bishop d7 I
had still a bit under pressure there yes
II 50 k 5 mm-hmm I thought Bishop before
but he has rook c7 then which is a bit
uncomfortable hmm still a bit tricky
I don't see a movie hmm amazing that I
suppose in some kind of trouble damn
time warning my book c7 I said it why
didn't I pay attention to it now ok ok
it's not see form ok I'd see phone
Bishop e6 is also going back and I have
no scram for this piece wow what a game
why is it taking so long for those
simple moves strange
no no square I hate to say it but I
think this guy is cheating thus this
time management is very weird he took
long times on simple moves and he it's
not even accelerating a little bit even
with the simple now could easily win on
time iam I know I'm down on time but his
super slow edge is not accelerating at
all you know I'm actually having a
winning position rah our third oh you
know I give him giving him the benefit
of the doubt ed client the draug white
boy is gay so i'm finding on time this
is a cheater in my in my book what he
did them sorry I'm very open about that
I think this was weird let's let's see
if how we can match the museum two
engine decision so c 5 i'm very
suspicious about the time usage because
he took seconds for simple recaptures
this is always very young very weird ok
so i went here play Bishop g5 like this
jack ok should be to a stock fish move
ok alright this is a fairly normal move
now you went back and I went here let's
see in some situations if we can ok
before this is all very normal what I'm
trying to do here is I'm matching this
against the computer moves now stock
wish wants to play b5 and he takes place
nights
hmm okay maybe I'm wrong down then the
it doesn't match that the engines moves
very clearly yeah a five is a bad move
really i have to i still can do this
Luke c7 it should be aid but I was
thinking if I was still hanging so it's
not such a big problem I mean so sorry
about that okay yeah this is still quite
okay I was really I was seeing a seeing
some goes there he has important and
still have this attack a brook see two
versus equal yeah a five was a bad move
luke t 1 this is a move that I mean it
if he is not cheating all the all the
compliments to him because it's very
strong this looks very normal yeah very
human this move you win the pawn this is
even stronger because I don't have any
square for my bishop which is not
running into a discovered attack you
know like here okay this is may be
possible rookie one is just
exceptionally strong but what what
really is is weird look a look at this
here I'm here he's double checking yeah
and my move Bishop takes b5 is very
clear what else i will take the second
porn I took there and he took say it
took 7 seconds to take the the bishop
and it's very clear I mean he had played
rook to e1 this really good move for
setting up in this double attack so you
have to be perfectly aware that night c4
is attacking
the bishop so he does he must see that
this hangs why is he taking seven
seconds to take it yeah and and again
seven seconds in a form of like Luke 2d6
where you can play any kind of rock t6
is the engine move by the way so this is
a strange game and this is strange
feeling actually prompted me to to
continue this because now he was playing
quicker but he also began to blunder
stuff here like here the the whole look
yeah what white is still here this is
still quite okay for white yeah yeah if
he goes instead of this if he goes
Bishop ecigs to cover this he has three
pawns and probably still very good
winning chances and this is giving up
the pony yeah actually offered and row I
don't really know why I mean it was a
very weird situation because I i mean i
was i was really outplayed there but i
felt like he was cheating and i didn't
know what to do there it's a bit it's a
bit of a strange game but this is a bit
of a suspicious those accounts always
are suspicious yeah he just started
their huge winning percentage yeah and
pretty fresh account yeah yeah look at
this like win win win win win win win
win win yeah win after win after win
getting getting all the way here and now
he's losing four games in a row that's
with flack always like yeah you don't
know you cannot really really tell if
this was fishy or not at the end I I won
I won on time yeah strange game you can
form your own opinion that I think it
was a bit a bit strange taking seconds
for simple recaptures is a weird it's a
weird thing to do okay well thanks for
watching